what I hope to do in this video is get a
little bit more practice and intuition
when we're multiplying multi digit
numbers so let's say that we wanted to
calculate what 7,000 times 6 is 7,000
times 6 now for some of you you might
did might just jump out at you that hey
look if I have 7 of anything and here I
have 7 thousands and I multiply that by
6 I'm now going to have 7 times 6 of
that thing or 42 of that thing and in
this case we have 42 thousands so you
might just be able to cut to the chase
and say hey look six times seven
thousands is going to be 42 thousands
and that's great if you can just cut to
the chase like that and another way to
think about is like look 6 times 7 is 42
and then since we're talking about
thousands we're not just talk about 7
when I'm at 7 thousands I have 3 zeros
here so I'm going to have 42 thousands 3
zeros there but I want to make sure that
we really understand what is going on
here this will also help us a little bit
of practice of our multiplication
properties so 7,000 is the same thing as
1,000 times 7 or 7 times 1000 it's seven
thousands or you could view it as a
thousand sevens either way so this is
the same thing as a thousand times 7
times 6 times times 6 and so you could
view it as you could do the thousand
times seven first which would be seven
thousand and then times 6 or you could
do the 7 times 6 first and this is this
right over here this is the associative
property of multiplication it sounds
very fancy but just say it says that hey
look we can multiply the 7 times 6 first
before we multiply by the thousand so we
could rewrite this as 1,000 times x and
if we going to do the 7 times 6 first we
could put the parenthesis around that
times 7 3 times 7 times 6 7 times 6
notice it's 1,000 times 7 times 6 I
could do a thousand times 7 first to get
7,000 or I could do the 7 times 6 first
to get and you know where this is going
so if you multiply the 7 times 6 first
you're going to get
forty-two and you're going to have a
thousand times 42 1000 times 42 so you
could view this as a thousand forty twos
or maybe a little bit more intuitively
you could view this as 40 mm so once
again we get to 42 40 mm and so the
whole reason some of y'all might have
just been able to do this immediately
your head and that's all good but it's
good to understand what's actually going
on here and the reason why I also broke
it up that way this way is that the
exercises on Khan Academy make you do
this to make sure that you really are
understanding how to break up these
numbers and how you can reassociate how
when you multiply them let's do another
one let's say that we wanted to figure
out let's say that we wanted to figure
out let me get our give ourselves some
space let's say that we wanted to figure
out what 56 56 times 8 is and there's a
bunch of different ways that you could
do it you could say that look 56 this is
the same thing as 55 tens that's 50 plus
6 ones plus 6 ones so 50 plus 6 and all
of that times 8 all of that times 8 and
then you can distribute the 8 and you
could say look this is going to be 50
times 8 so it's going to be 50 times 8
plus 6 times 8 plus 6 times 8 plus 6
times 8 and 50 times 8 well 5 times 8 is
40 but not we're not just saying 5 we're
saying 5 tens so 5 10 times 8 is going
to be 40 tens or it's going to be 400
another way to think about it 5 times 8
is 40 but we're not talking about 5
we're going about 5 tens so it's going
to be 40 tens so 50 times 8 is 400 and
then 6 times 8 is of course equal to 48
so this is going to be equal to 400 448
and this is actually how I do things in
my head when I do it in my head I have
to see I'm not writing things down like
this but I think okay 56 56 times 8 I
could break that up into 50 and six and
eight times 50 well that's four hundred
or forty tens you could say eight times
five tens is going to be 40 tens or four
hundred and then eight times six is
going to be 48 so it's going to be four
hundred plus 48 once you get some
practice you're going to be able to do
things like things like this in your
head and if it helps we can also
visualize this looking at an area of a
rectangle so imagine this rectangle
right over here and let's say that let's
say that this dimension right over here
is eight it is eight units tall so
that's the eight and this entire
dimension this entire length this entire
length here is 56 so the area of this
rectangle is going to be 56 times 8
which is what we set to figure out and
to do that what we could break it up
into is 50 and 6 so this first section
right over here this first section right
over here this has length we could say
this has length 50 that has length 50
and then the second section this has
length 6 this has length 6 and the
reason why we broke it up this way is
because we can maybe in our heads or
without too much work figure out what 8
times 50 is and then separately figure
out what 8 times 6 is so separately
figure out the areas of these two pieces
of the big rectangle and then add them
together so what's 8 times 5 tens well
it's going to be 40 tens or 400 this is
going to be 400 square units it's going
to the area of this yellow part and then
what's 8 times 6 well we know that's
going to be 48 square units so the
entire rectangle is going to be the
eight times the 50 or the 50 times the 8
the 400 this area the yellow area plus
the magenta area plus the 8 times the 6
the 48 which is 448 448 is going to be
the area of the whole thing 8 times 56